hey guys it's justine and today we're
checking out the brand new samsung
galaxy z flip 4 i am so excited about
this i've told you i think every single
year that the new iteration of this
phone that has come out that it is my
absolute favorite device yes i know i'm
ijustine i love apple i love iphones but
as for android there is just something
about this device that is just so
appealing it's so beautiful it's so
small it's so compact and just this flip
i just can't get enough of it it's goals
so i've been testing this out for the
past week and one of my favorite things
is how seamless this hinge feels now
that doesn't feel like there's a huge
upgrade from the previous version but i
can definitely tell a difference also
the hinge is now a little bit more flat
as opposed to rounded so it does kind of
feel like it's a little bit smaller also
as you guys know when i do my reviews
i'm coming at this from a content
creator's perspective i'm someone who is
always filming videos i'm always taking
photos i'm posting things on social
media and this is honestly such an
incredible device for doing all of those
things now the cameras on this are by no
means the highest rated cameras that are
out on the market but one of the things
that i do love about this is the ease of
use of this device because you can just
kind of place it anywhere and take
photos and instantly start filming the
video quality the photos they all look
really really good so even if you are
getting this to create content and
you're a little bit worried about
they're not the best cameras on the
market how will i ever survive you're
gonna be okay we can get through this
together let's go take some photos
so satisfying
so what's new with the new galaxy z flip
well it has a new slimmer hinge a larger
3 700 milliamp hour battery and you can
quick charge it up to 50 in 30 minutes
it also has wireless power share which
is pretty cool if you need to share some
battery with a friend the 6.7 inch
display has 120 hertz adaptable refresh
rate it's also 45 stronger with a new
ultra thin glass it features a
snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 processor it's
ipx8 water resistance it has an upgraded
main camera that is 65 percent brighter
and improved stabilization and tracking
this has 8 gigs of ram and you can
configure the storage from 128 up to 512
gigs the starting price is 9.99 and it
comes in this color which is borah
purple graphite and there's two new
colors pink gold and blue you'll also be
able to further customize up to 75
different color combinations with their
bespoke editions
[Music]
so there are three cameras on this there
is a front facing camera and the two
here on the back now the two on the back
there's a wide and ultra wide and those
are both 12 megapixels and the one thing
that is missing from this device is a
telephoto lens i do wish that there was
a telephoto but of course you do have
some optical zoom so it'll kind of make
up for it but there really is no
replacing that third lens that will give
you that telephoto look now the front
facing is a 10 megapixel selfie camera
which will also shoot 4k 30 and the rear
facing cameras will allow you to shoot
4k 30 and 60 frames a second which is
pretty exciting this does have an
improved battery life over the previous
version so this now is a 3700 milliamp
hour battery and because this is also
running the snapdragon 8 plus gen
processor those two things together
should improve our battery life
significantly so i'm excited to keep
testing this out and to see how the
battery life is holding up so far so
good this is the front cover display and
it's so cool to see how far we've come
since the first version because this is
actually a functional display now so we
have access to all sorts of things we
have all kinds of widgets that we can
add on here you can get your
notifications that pop up and you can
even use this to take photos you can
double tap and this will give you the
full view so you can see everything
you can see the full image and you can
take that photo by just tapping
you can also do video if you keep
scrolling i love that on the new flip 4
it has a gorilla glass back and this is
matte this is not shiny like the
previous versions so this alleviates a
lot of those issues that we used to have
with fingerprints and it's also
beautiful one of the features that i
like is flex mode so it's basically
turning your phone into like a little
tiny mini laptop so when you go like
this and you fold it a lot of the apps
are now
optimized to take advantage of this fold
so for example take instagram here when
i fold it it automatically moves my
video portion up there and i have all of
my controls down here on the bottom so i
can make my video i can add music i can
add filters all like a tiny little mini
laptop okay i'm gonna do an instagram
live now this is great because i can
basically just set this here i am now
live it's like you guys are helping us
make a video right now this freaking
flip is just so cool and it's
technically a fold but it's folding it
in in half the other way what camera
setup are you using this is uh it was
a74 oh my god okay so k black bought
three badges so now their profile photo
will glow
shut up i will see you guys i guess in
the next one jake says bye we're going
to continue
on our way so now it's time to test out
the video and one of the things that i
like is when i'm filming myself
with the back cameras i can't ever
actually see myself but with this i can
turn on the cover screen preview so i
can turn the cover screen preview on and
i will be able to use the front facing
so with this i'm able to film myself and
i'm able to actually see if i'm in a
frame i'm speechless like this is so
great because you're going to be able to
actually film using the high quality
cameras and you'll be able to see if
you're in frame are you in frame yep am
i in frame yep
[Music]
so now this is a super steady mode so
we're gonna see
so now we're testing out the
front-facing camera how does it look how
does it sound here it is
here it is there's jake hello there's a
dog oh there's so many doggies oh so
cute so cute thank you guys so much for
watching i had so much fun getting a
chance to check out the flip i'm so
excited to also do a video on the fold
but i really wanted to do this one first
because this is still my favorite form
factor as i've said before
i absolutely love this phone i love this
device and i'm so excited to see all of
the future iterations of flips and folds
by samsung samsung has been doing a
really great job at pushing the envelope
and really creating a whole entire
market based around these foldable
devices so i am 100
here for it oh that's so satisfying
if you guys are new here and haven't
already please subscribe to my channel
and also hit the bell so you'll be
notified when i post new videos tech
season is going to be here before you
know it it's basically actually let me
check my calendar
um yep it's here
stay tuned for more fun videos i look
forward to seeing you guys in the next
one
bye
you